c'est dans cette clinique plutôt
discrète en banlieue de montréal qui a
été conçu ce fameux tests cognitifs
ici les gens attendent sereinement
d'être évalués mais une personne en
particulier aura retenu l'attention
partout dans le monde et nine de la
mémoire ou qu'avant gens depuis ce matin
le téléphone ne dérougit pas les médias
du monde entier veulent parler au
docteur ziad nasreddine pour parler de
ce test que le président des états unis
a spécifiquement choisi synthèse de
mémoire surtout donc ça a évolué la
mémoire court terme c'est elle qui nous
permet de racheter de nouvelles
informations d'apprendre de nouvelles
choses
donc les personnes qui ont une maladie
d'alzheimer souvent si cette même moment
là qui est affecté donc s'il
enregistreuse qu'on dit que je dis à mes
patients qui fonctionne moins bien tout
ce qui a déjà été enregistré dans le
passé on a accès à ces informations la
mêlée nouvelles informations soient
affectés donc le but du test de demander
des questions de faire retenir des mots
5 mo par exemple comme dans ce test là
et quelques minutes après on leur
demande quels sont les cinq mots pouvoir
leur capacité d'apprendre de nouvelles
informations dans notre chemin passe le
test haut la main la maison blanche
annonce fièrement les résultats 30 sur
30 pour dans notre chambre
seuls 5% réussissent à avoir une telle
note le test aura duré dix minutes
l'objectif détecté plusieurs types de
démence ou de dysfonctionnements
cognitif mais ce n'est pas un test
psychiatrique précise le neurologue le
teich ne valait pas bien sûr les
troubles de personnalité ou les maladies
psychiatriques les maladies mentales
il a vu plus tôt les maladies
neurologiques démence frontale démence
vasculaire
maladie accordent oui c'est des maladies
qui sont facilement détectables par ce
test
zied nasreddine a étudié la médecine à
l'université de sherbrooke où il s'est
spécialisé en neurologie
originaire du liban il est arrivé au
québec à l'âge de 15 ans en 2005 il
publie son test cognitif
c'est une fierté de pouvoir dire oui
qu'on a pu s'y à montréal contribué un
test cognitif qui s'est rendu jusqu'à la
maison blanche
mais pour commenter la performance de
monsieur trempe comme tel je peux pas
dire vraiment ce qu'il y a une autre
condition pour la réalité quelle raison
ils l'ont fait passer il avait l'air
fier d'avoir réussi ce test là donc ça
fait sourire un petit peu c'est sûr je
dis ça parce que c'est comme s'ils
devaient démontrer au monde entier qu'il
est intacte cognitivement voilà donc
pour l'évaluation des capacités
cognitives du président mais sera t elle
suffisante pour faire taire les rumeurs
sur sa santé mentale
ici asobo de l'eger guise radio canada
montréal